PROFESSOR BLADE
KOTELLY: I think the way
that we open their thinking
in the process of teaching
it is to start connecting our
process to everything else they
do in life.
So start to really make
sure that they understand
the connections between the
design process being used
for something as
simple as planning
a birthday party to something
more complicated, like making
a mechanical system, designing
a phone, or something like that.
We try to have them reflect on
it in their normal existence.
So, do a design
critique of something,
and come back in with that.
So we can actually
have them think
about oh, the design
of a simple object
in my life, what
do I like about it?
What don't I like about it?
And then they start thinking
a little bit differently,
because they realize that
all the ideas they've
had about certainty,
these principles
are true-- they realize,
well, they aren't always true.
In fact, they're
only true in context.
PROFESSOR JOEL
SCHINDALL: Part of what
we do in the class is to
ask provocative questions.
Students will give
an answer that they
think is the normal
answer to the question.
And Blade will say,
why do you think that?
The students are a
little irritated.
I think that because that's
the right thing to think.
But it turns out that it's not
the only way to look at it.
And they simply
haven't challenged
that way of looking at.
And sometimes we have to
walk a little fine line
to not be too
irritating with this.
But the fact is, the irritation
provokes the expanded
exploration, the sensitivity
to things around them,
which is what we want to
draw out in this class.
PROFESSOR BLADE KOTELLY:
Some of the other goals
include just doing a
really clean, simple design
process they can
apply to anything.
Being able to operate
as a designer does.
So in the context of
whatever they're doing,
know how to evaluate systems.
Thinking about people.
Understanding stakeholders.
Understanding a little bit about
the architecture of a system
and how to abstract it out.
Understanding how to
write good requirements.
Being able to usability
test something
to see if someone actually can
use it, they like using it.
Understanding the psychology
of human interaction
with technology is
really important.
Being able to think that
the brand of something
actually affects the
way someone uses it.
It's not just the logo
or something else,
but the way the whole system
feels and the identity it
produces in the mind
of someone that's
unique compared
to other systems.
And hopefully they're able
to see all this whenever
they create anything.
PROFESSOR JOEL SCHINDALL:
Blade had previous experience
when we put the course
together in speech-activated
satisfaction systems,
or answering systems.
There's no easy name for it
in the language, or at least
I'm missing it, but when you
call American Airlines to get
information about a flight, or
when you call to order a pizza,
you'll often interact with an
automated voice system which
gives you certain prompts,
listens to your responses,
and based on those responses
it gives you other prompts.
Most people find them
very exasperating,
because somehow they don't
seem to be foreseeing correctly
the issue that
you're dealing with.
And so we have the
students design systems.
Initially, we have them
design a simple pizza ordering
system or simple banking
transaction system,
but then as their
project for the term,
they will do a more
complicated system.
Something like, one
of them did a system--
I forget the exact name--
but it was for a parent
to let a child call this
automated system and it would
say, "Hi, this is Santa's elf.
And what would you like
for Christmas this year?"
And the child will
respond with what
it would like to
get for Christmas.
And the system is prompted
to listen for things
and it will record the
child's answer, say
that's a wonderful thing,
we'll see what we can do.
And then the system
actually will call or text
the child's parent to
tell the child's parent
what the child asked
for for Christmas.
It was a very
clever idea, and it
was implemented in such a
way that people who used it
actually had fun and
enjoyed the answers.
The challenge for
the students is
that you'd think that designing
a speech-activated system
is an easy thing to do.
And you quickly get
humbled by the fact
that the first person
who you have try it
comes up with a perfectly
logical response that
is not what you had predicted.
And it forces you to
get into the user's head
and look at what do
I need to provide
the user in the
way of information
and what responses do I need
to be prepared to respond to,
so that I can have an effective
dialogue with this user?
It's a wonderful way of
training the students
in how to be methodical,
how to put together a plan,
how to engineer something,
but how to also test it
with users and deal
with the issues that
come up with those users.